[Music]
this week on
forward happy holidays coming up we have
our editor and audience picks for the
best of 2023 the future of AI cancel
culture the 2024 elections all this and
more coming up on the best of happy 2023
and see you in 2024
everybody
it is my pleasure to Welcome to the
podcast the author of the new book
what's our problem you know him as wait
but why Tim Urban welcome Tim thank you
very much so in your book you talk about
there being something of a ladder of
thinking which I enjoyed a great deal uh
and I can let you dig into the the four
levels the highest level is scientist
what entertained me was that the next
level was um I believe sports fan
uh and then the level below that was
attorney which you're like wait like
sports fans are smarter than attorneys
I'm get in a lot of trouble for this
I've gotten some very angry attorneys um
I'm not talking about actual scientists
sports fans attorneys I'm talking about
each of these is representing a certain
like way of thinking a certain goal and
um so when I talk about scientists first
of all so so the the the premise of here
is that this is a vertical ladder
vertical axis um we talked so much about
Right Center in politics right um and
like when you know we talk about when I
hear forward party I don't see Center as
much it is Center horizontally but what
I see is actually something that is
we're trying to introduce the third
dimension like we there are actually
people in Ford who are like no no avoid
the Centrist thing though it does work
out like that a lot because but um the
the fact is there are people who are
part of Ford who are Libertarians there
people are Ford who are like considered
essentially like far lefties yeah well
and the point is if if all you have is
one ACC
and you're trying to say Hey you know
we're so polarized we need more people
on the center what what what comes along
with that is the assumption that if you
have a far-left view for example you're
you know you believe in socialism um uh
and um or you you you you know you think
there's a real deep underlying systemic
racism whatever it's an assumption that
that person must be tribal and and
non-thinking and and that's not
necessarily true actually and likewise
it's also assuming that if you have
views in the center if you happen to
have views that means you're a great
thinker that's not necessarily true
either I know a lot of people who are
Centrist in their views but they're
super dogmatic and they're actually
dogmatic about being Centrist and so if
you make it a square and now you have
this other axis it frees that up so now
it's like um you can have people across
the the horizontal Spectrum up high and
down low so the fact that you've
introduced the second dimension of
politics I think is so invaluable and
what what you've done is you introduced
four levels of thinking so uh scientist
I think people instinctively can imagine
what that is it's like hey let's see
what the facts and the data say and then
uh sports
fan uh then the level below that is
attorney which is you're just arguing
for a side and you're not even trying
toig the way I think about it is and
then I also want to say the fourth level
just so that there's something below
attorney is Zealot which we all kind of
recognize now it it really stems from
there's two motivations that you could
have when you're trying to come up with
your beliefs there's two ways to form
beliefs right um one and I think this is
a character in our brain is just wants
truth is is humble doesn't think doesn't
identify with ideas like let's if my
idea is wrong tell me and I'll change it
let's let's get closer to the truth
right seems very rational and then the
other way is totally different and this
is this kind of primitive software in
our head who identifies with ideas and
and that goal is to confirm the ideas
you already believe and to keep
believing them and to make sure that
that anyone you know you get you hate
anyone who disagrees with you on them
and and you don't like to argue very
much because or you might like to argue
but you'll never change your mind
because changing your mind is an
existential crisis when you're in that
mode so we both have we all have both of
these and the latter to me is about when
you're on that top rung it's that
rational what I would call a higher mind
um that cares about truth is fully
running the show so you just are you're
thinking like that you just are looking
for Truth Now actual career scientists
are often not like this by the way this
is not even praising career scientists
this is thinking like a scientist like
the perfect scientist and then when you
go down to the sports fan rung of the
latter you're still that's that's a
second one so you're still a little the
the truth character in your head is
still has the edge but there's this new
uh there's this other um ulterior kind
of motive where now a little part of
you're really root I use sports fan
because it's like the sport Sports fence
doesn't want corrupt refs they still
want the game played fairly they care
about truth in the end they want to know
who really was better who really won but
they're rooting they're rooting so
they're they're they're they have
confirmation bias and this is so this is
what you know it's like you still you
still care about truth but there's a lot
of confirmation bias infecting your
thinking process Tom Brady didn't
deflate those footballs actually use
that example because I'm from Newton
Mass and I was I There is almost nothing
you could have told me back then that
would have gotten me to say you know I
don't think the Patriots earned their
Super Bowls I mean I the amount of
confirmation bias um and I still think
they earned all their Super Bowls by the
way um but but the tribalism is very
powerful Tim but if someone said you
know Hey listen you can if you can press
this button and the refs are going to
rig the Super Bowl in favor of the
Patriots I wouldn't have done that and I
don't think most sports fans would you
don't yeah I mean the point it's it's
that you still it's not fun if you win
by cheating you still want your team to
win fair and square so it's this nuanced
thing and the attorney is the rung below
and the difference between the attorney
and the sports fan both of them are in
the middle so they both have both of
these motives going on but the attorney
in the end it's kind of Switched more to
I want my team to win yeah yeah you you
you will you won't change your mind and
the end you care more about being right
than getting it right then you care more
about being right than the truth deep
down and and you know that because that
person will argue and they'll come up
with all this evidence because they
still understand there's a truth finding
process but they're a brick wall you
will never actually change their mind
and so the reason I use attorney for
this real world attorneys are part of a
two attorney system and they know that
the best way for the system toine truth
is for them to make the best possible
case for one side of the argument
because they know the other person the
other attorney is doing the same on the
other side so that the clash of the two
the jury can see the truth right so they
can still be a truth caring person as an
attorney but they know their job is to
do this now if the problem when you're
thinking like an attorney is you only
have one attorney in your head you don't
have the whole the both sides so you
you're basically instead of trying to
find the truth you'll build a case in
your head for why you're correct and and
it's not that hard to do if you want to
if you want to confirm any belief you
can find evidence seeming that seems
like it's evidence out there for it and
then finally get to the Zealot Rong and
now it's the the part of your brain that
wants to confirm your ideas is entirely
running the show there's no Elementary
truth it's like you know you're right
you don't even need evidence you don't
even need to argue because the sky is
blue you don't need evidence that the
sky is blue when you actually the person
arguing against you is clearly a bad
person not yet they're a terrible
exactly and the at the top someone who
you disagree with is is they're
interesting why do you disagree maybe
they're wrong but as you go down it go
goes from wrong to stupid to evil to bad
evil person if they disagree with me and
you now you're so out of your mind when
you're in that Zone by the way we've all
been there i' I've been there like when
you're in that zone and you think that
anyone who disagrees with you is a
deeply bad person you've gotten totally
sucked into human craziness you're not
you You've Lost Your Truth finding
capabilities in that moment so um I love
this second dimension this high low and
so you use these fun metaphors uh of
genies and Gollum where you you had uh
originally in the you know better
version of politics you had people
arguing for their version um in terms of
facts and and policies and then the
other people on the other side um but
then uh unfortunately we've gotten now
brought down a couple of levels where
it's become more tribalistic and less
reasoning um and uh you characterize
essentially like the the gollum on each
side as unfortunately so certainly and
I'm going to say on the repan side uh
like the nastier um
more unreasoning elements of taking hold
of the party with the rise of trump um
but then you say that there is a version
on the other side too and you referenced
it a little bit when you talked about
what's going on in campuses yeah I think
um I think that the it's not that
politics should be people being nice and
agreeing like when I think of high Rong
politics it's heated it's passionate
right there's people protesting there's
there's vigorous debate um they might
not like each other but they're in the
end they're fighting about ideas and the
underlying thing that unites everyone up
there whether they disagree or agree is
this common goal of a better country and
the it's like a two lawyers in a
courtroom their Clash moves the country
forward right it's like this it's like
this positive sum
game when you go to the low Rong
politics which I sometimes like to call
political Disney World because it
there you know it's the land of good
guys and evil villains right and and it
it's um the mindset is not let's make a
better country together even though
that's what maybe people think it is
that's not what's going on it's let's
defeat the bad guys we're the good right
we're perfectly righteous we have no
flaws and they're evil and demonic and
let's defeat the bad guys and if only we
had it our way the country would be
perfect but the there you know whatever
it's this very Us Versus Them
concept that's a zero sum game that
moves the country backwards when their
Clash hurts the whole country well while
The Clash on high wrong politics pushes
the country forward exactly so they're
both clashes again these are both he a
subtle difference sometimes but one is
arguing about ideas and they're
experimenting and and it's not about
it's not like an ethnic tension like
type thing it's not like a um you know
evil and good it's it's like we're all
here trying to do the same thing I think
you're wrong but let's discuss it and at
the bottom it is it's this war of not
ideas but it's a war of peoples it's
it's it gets into the same kind of thing
that creates religious wars zealots
versus zealots I mean it can get very
very dangerous very fast yeah and and by
the way when you're in that environment
you feel a lot of pressure from your own
side to any kind of you know
legitimizing the other side you'll feel
it from your own side it's each side
kind of bullies themselves into staying
that way there's a lot of Conformity
pressure it's it's and it's not it's
different cultures if it's when you're
down there it's not cool to say I don't
know what I think about this policy
because that makes you seem like a
wishy-washy you know callous whatever um
and it's not cool to uh say maybe they
have a point right on the top in the
higher higher rung culture it's actually
very cool to say I don't know it makes
you look like you have some humility and
it it's it's actually um speaking with
unearned conviction up there makes you
seem stupid while on the bottom you know
in the low rungs honored conviction
exactly and the more conviction you
speak with about how good we are and how
bad they are the smarter and better you
seem as a person so how did the Golems
take control and and you write about
this in the book where like there were
different process where you know like
that you had the right-wing Gollum uh
kind of rise to power I think gingr had
a lot to do with it well so so yeah the
the the I use the term Gollum for like
it's like the emergent property of like
low rung political group like it's an
echo chamber which is a bunch of people
right who who are scared to disagree
with each other but there's an emerging
thing there which like think of this
like big dumb giant that I call a Golem
that like runs you know tramps like
Godzilla through Society a liberal
democracy is always going to have Golems
it's always going to have these these
kind of political tribes or religious
tribes or whatever um and the the thing
that makes a liberal democracy special
isn't that it has it gets rid of these
it's that it has an immune system to
keep them from taking over so there's a
I think of it as kind of the liberal
immune system um and the you know the or
the high rung immune system and and what
what that's made of is kind of um a very
proud culture of like how we do things
here and there's a Live and Let Live
Concept in a place like the us and it's
like regardless of what you you know
believe or who you are like Live and Let
Live as long as you're not harming
someone else do your thing and and and
and let other people live right and
that's not how a Golem thinks they they
the go the go their goal of the Golem is
to um to enforce its ways on everyone
but again the immune system is people
who will stand up against that so first
of all the law doesn't let them use
physical Force so that's a huge
disadvantage that most in other
countries a Golem can actually execute
you and things like that and then
without physical force all they have is
you know ability ability to socially
bully people and culturally control and
so the liberal immune system is people
who say that's not how we do things here
and we'll push back on them and what's
happened I think in the last decade few
decades but especially most recent
decades maybe due to social media and
and and a few other things people have
gotten too very very scared of these
Golems they've become scarier you know
and that has turned into the immune the
people stopping standing up for Liberal
values and going quiet and that's the
immune system failing that's that's you
know in a bit when you scale up a bunch
of scared individuals you get a in a
mass scale you get this immune system
failing and these Golems kind of like
Godzilla tramping through Society in a
way that they really couldn't do in the
older days you know they this is this is
pretty
new
happy holidays you know what's tough to
do during holiday season eat right and
not gain weight and not frankly get a
little extra tummy going because you
don't have time you're on the go the way
you can make it so you stay healthy and
charged up in the right way is to use
Factor America's number one ready to eat
meal delivery service Chef prepared
dietician improved ready to eat meals
delivered straight to your door this is
the service that's going to change your
life
if
[Music]
it is my pleasure to Welcome to the
podcast three term member of congress
former CEO of talenti gelato Democratic
presidential candidate Congressman Dean
Phillips joining us today welcome Dean
hey Andrew great to be with you my
friend you are beaming in from New
Hampshire is that right how are things
going I'm literally beaming because it
is the most amazing joyful inspirational
reinvigorating month of my life it's
going great you know there's a a massive
as you well know a massive disconnect
between Washington and the real world
and people here in the granite state are
amazing ready for change completely
disenchanted with what they're seeing on
both ballots right now and I'm excited
about January 23rd it's I think it's
going to be a real surprise yeah so you
and I have known each other uh for about
a year or so uh we met in DC when you
were a member and uh I liked you
immediately because we were at a
campaign Finance form event and you said
hey DC is even worse than I thought I'm
the only member who doesn't dial for
dollars I thought I was kind of here to
legislate and do something good and uh
and I heard this and I said wow like
more of America should hear about this
guy but the the process you're going
through right now is helping others
imagine you as president what is that
Vision it's January 2025 you get sworn
in uh your the new president of United
States um what is top of the list in
terms of the things that you want to
express or get done let me start with
the most important which is how I will
lead and I'm going to lead very
differently I'm going to have a Team of
Rivals in the White House Andrew uh not
unlike Abraham Lincoln put together uh
in the 1860s during the worst crisis in
American history to that point the Civil
War he recognized that every American
had to have their voice inside the White
House he needed to put people at that
table who had different perspectives but
had to lead the country together and I
think it's time for every single future
president of the United States to ensure
that he or she does not just populate
the White House staff and cabinet with
people who all see things the same way I
think that's actually destructive to
democracy and it is destroying the
country that's one I'll also have a
youth cabinet it's time to bring young
people's voices into the White House a
delegate from every one of the 50 states
all Races religions colors backgrounds
uh and politics and geographies uh to
come up with great ideas about social
media regulation about the future of AI
both the blessings and the curses
climate change gun violence prevention
the things that young people are most
focused on for good reason and have
great ideas about I'm going to employ
zerob based budgeting I'm going to
finally have every single agency of the
United States federal government
assessed by an outside consulting firm
to identify ways to save money deliver
Services better more effici efficiently
and effectively and finally the Pentagon
will pass an audit these are absolutes
as the next leader I'd be the Bro I'd
have the most experience Andrew
strangely enough of any recent president
having built and led companies having
served as the board chair of a large
Health System uh a regent at a
university a board chair of a charitable
Foundation a board member of a public
company and now three terms in the
United States Congress a member of House
Democratic Leadership ranking member of
the Middle East subcommittee on Foreign
Affairs and also the vice ranking member
of the small business committee I have
very broad experience and I will use
that management experience which very
few occupants of the White House have
had to lead better uh and most of all to
develop Common Ground if we do not
repair the country use common sense and
decency and restore faith in government
nothing I talk about right now is going
to matter so what's next affordability
affordability and affordability there is
a massive disconnect between Washington
and the rest of the country it's it's
it's staggering how desperate people are
right now housing if you can even find
it is unaffordable mortgage rates have
soared people cannot afford to buy new
homes we are seven 6 and A5 million
units shy to meet the demand in the
United States and we have about a half a
million human beings Americans sleeping
outside every single night not just New
York and San Francisco up here in
Manchester New Hampshire veterans
sleeping in the Parks it's atrocious and
we have to do a 7 million unit
initiative immediately to produce
housing in America Healthcare
66% of every of all bankruptcies in the
United States are from medical debt from
medical debt in the United States of
America we spend twice as much as any
developed nation in the world our
outcomes are mid-pack we allow and I
state that again we allow pharmaceutical
companies to sell their products in the
United States for three four five times
more than anywhere in the world when I'm
President we will find a way working
together to ensure that none of those
companies can sell their products here
for a penny more than they do in Canada
Mexico Great Britain France or Japan or
Australia period it's not that hard and
we're going to change the delivery model
from a fee for service to a capitation
model so we actually get away from what
we what is really a sickcare system we
don't have health care it's a sick care
system so that's health care and then we
have education $1.7 trillion in student
debt uh at 5% interest that's about 80
some billion dollars a year that's
burdening families and young people who
can barely get ahead and we've need
tuition-free college we also need to
make sure that that the debt that exists
right now I believe should be interest
free and we should absolve the debt of
any person who is willing to develop
their uh credentials or career in
something that serves the public so
these are common sense Solutions and
then groceries you know Andrew I you
know I come from the Vodka business when
I was in that business retailers were
not allowed legally could not charge us
what they call slotting fees those are
the prices you pay to rent the Shelf to
put your products on the Shelf but in
the grocery business when I was in the
ice cream business not only can they
charge you all the grocery chains around
the country are charging rent to the
bread makers and the butter makers and
the cereal makers to put your products
on the Shelf so why do we have high
grocery prices of course it's obvious we
have too little competition and we have
a system not unlike the political
industrial complex the duopoly uh that
is literally making things more
expensive than necessary so if we don't
address these things and we don't raise
the foundation uh we are going to be in
big trouble and by the way uh I know you
are a big fan of Ubi I'm looking at a
bill right now that would do a pilot
around the country because I think AI is
going to almost require that we
completely change the lens of us
capitalism if we hope to remain a
democracy for many many years to come so
those things are on my mind border
security is on my mind chaos in our
cities is on my mind and probably most
importantly if we do not become a
country that ensures security for every
American and peace and prosperity in the
United States and overseas uh we are not
doing our jobs and I'm just afraid the
current generation of leaders from the
West Bank all the way to the West Wing
have got to be replaced with Next
Generation leaders who understand what's
coming who have a different worldview
different competencies and most of all
are ready to work together to solve
problem s stop fighting each other and
start fighting for each other that's my
agenda it's not rocket science it's
entirely Common Sense well I love how
you're tackling the main uh sources of
misery in terms of costs uh so that's
housing health care and education uh I'd
imagine you have some uh thoughts around
vocational and apprenticeship folks who
who aren't um heading to college I'm
curious about your ideas on what we
originally connected on which is
campaign Finance reform one of the
things that I suggest to folks Dean is
is some people say to me it's like oh
Dean's a Democrat um and I was a
Democrat I left the party in 2021
because I didn't think that uh the
solutions were necessarily going to come
from within the party and what I try and
convey to folks is like no I mean sure
Dean's been a Democrat uh his his
political career um but Dean is actually
uh in many ways situated to be a
profound change agent if he wins this
thing and I joke and this is before the
machine has been Shing him every
day like he he wasn't a fan of the
machine even when it was like it was
like totally fine with him um so uh what
can we do to fix our broken terrible
campaign Finance system I'm so glad you
asked because you know that's why I I
did this work to resist Donald Trump and
to expose the truth about a system that
I really do believe is starting to work
against all of us not just the left not
just the right but the left as well and
I've been a proud Democrat my whole life
I intend to continue to I'm running as a
Democrat for a reason U but I think I
represent an extraordinary number of
Democrats around the country that are
growing very concerned about the
underpinnings of this entire party uh
and I believe that this is a time to
make a choice and to be courageous about
it and those choices have to start with
actually reformation and transparent
transparency of how this party operates
which in my estimation is shockingly uh
opaque dangerous and disenfranchising
but as it relates to reform Andrew um
first of all money and politics you know
I'm the only member of the entire House
and Senate 535 people that accepts no
pack money no lobbyist money no member
money and I don't have a leadership pack
I'm the only one out of 535 people which
means I find it hard to find friends and
colleagues to go to dinner with in
Washington on a Wednesday night because
they're all going to pack dinners
getting their white envelope with the
$5,000 in it going to another event I
hate that I also I don't do call time I
don't run across the street and dial for
dollars it's atrocious I actually wrote
A bill Andrew to prevent fundraising in
Washington between breakfast and dinner
because I see so many people in Congress
spending every moment that they had free
leaving committee meetings leaving
committee meetings to go call people for
money so what's the problem with that
when Congress is spending 10,000 hours
per week raising money well here's the
problem who are they raising it from
only the wealthy and the well connected
because you got to fish where the fish
are it's natural which means you're only
hearing from you're only congregating
with really wealthy people of course
they have expectations especially the
packs and the lobbyists that's their job
to influence you and we allow it the
bigger issue I think is this Andrew when
you're spending all that time with
people of great means by definition you
have no time to spend with people of
modest means which is the overwhelming
majority of this country 60% living
paycheck to paycheck 40% cannot afford a
$400 repair and 32% of the entire wealth
of the United States of America is held
by just
1% so when 535 members of Congress 534
because I don't do this are spending all
their time with really wealthy people
you're ignoring the people who really
need help so why do we think
trumpism happened because someone said
you know what I get it I'm going to give
them voice I'm going to pretend that I
care about them and I think it's time
for Democrats and independents and
thoughtful people in all parties to
start extending invitations but I'm a
Democrat I want to extend invitations to
disenfranchised angry people currently
supporting Donald Trump to join this
team the dean team because I get it I'm
angry too I want to drain that swamp of
the corruption of the low bar for ethics
I think we need term limits I think we
need open primaries I think we need rank
Choice voting I think we need to end
Jerry mandering and I think it's time to
return to some form of publicly financed
campaigns so that every single candidate
from Joe Biden to Donald Trump to Dean
Phillips to Andrew Yang to Ronda santis
and Chris Christie and Nikki Haley don't
have to spend so much of their time
appealing for
resources I think it's anti-democratic
and I think it is completely undermining
the very foundations of democracy at the
very least I'll tell you I'm going to
expose the truth I'm going to continue
on this mission and I think that is in
my in in my entire agenda both policy is
affordability peace and reform and I
call it relieve repair and
reimagine hey YouTube thanks for
watching please do hit like And
subscribe and hit that Bell if you want
to be notified every time a new episode
drops probably on Mondays but hit that
Bell and thank
you
it is my pleasure to Welcome to the
podcast one of the foremost AI experts
in the world he recently testified the
US Senate also sold an AI company to
Uber has a doctorate from MIT one of the
champions for Humanity when it comes to
AI Gary Marcus welcome Gary thanks for
having me man so fast forward to today
you are testifying the US Senate as to
the pitfalls around AI what did you say
to them and what do you think the that
the news accounts are getting right and
wrong not not of your testimony but just
generally where AI is concerned it's
might be worth filling in something
there so um you know I gave you a sort
of story of my research career mentioned
that I did some entrepreneurial work but
I really in the last several months
moved hard into policy I had thought
about policy before um I had actually
proposed a CERN for AI in 2017 which is
an idea that UK has been picking up on
lately um so I thought about policy
before but I was still kind of more in
the academic world and what I saw really
around when Bing and Bard came out in
February was a sudden acceleration on
the part of the tech companies that felt
irresponsible to me and that's really
what shifted me and how I wound up
testifying in the Senate it already been
writing a lot about the Perils of
misinformation and saying like we need
to take seriously even if these machines
aren't very smart I really think they're
not very sophisticated they can still do
a lot of harm and so I started writing a
lot about that and that was really what
led me to the Senate is I started to
make the case that we need some
regulation I had a TED Talk in April and
I made that about having a global um an
international Agency for AI and so I
started really getting concern they were
racing very quickly without really
knowing how to control these systems and
that that caused a lot of dangers both
short-term and longterm maybe we can get
into that um and I think made a clear
and articulate case and that's how I
wound up testifying in the Senate so
there a little bit of background so so
people ask me sometimes about the
potential short-term dangers and I I
said well let's see you could have uh uh
an erosion of Truth because you have a
thousand different versions of reality
and deep fake videos and and audio
recordings and what have you uh you
could have rampant identity theft uh
because of the fact that my wife can
call me and ask me to do something but
it's not my
wife there have been real cases of that
right there there have been people who
for example got call saying their kids
were kidnapped and then they wired money
you know Bitcoin to people who are
really scam artists um so this is
actually happening with the the the um
voice faking stuff so so the so these
are the some of the negative scenarios
that I've described that I find totally
plausible um not even plausible uh near
certain because you have these tools and
then guess what human nature is what it
is and so you might have people putting
out videos and uh deep fakes for various
purposes uh certainly the identity theft
that's just for commercial gain where
you think oo like that this is a way I
can I can get some money in a way that
that can't be traced to me effectively
so those are the obvious ones um but
there are also some inobvious ones yeah
there there's a lot so I mean first of
all I'll say that the threat to
democracy is the one that worries me the
most like I just don't see how the 2024
election isn't going to be a show
there's going to be so much use of these
tools um and you're see a lot of October
surprises you know fake stories about
this or that candidate having a heart
attack or whatever um there's going to
be a ton of that and these new tools
make it cheaper to make misinformation
they allow people to make it wholesale
rather than retail like just much larger
quantities and very convincing and we've
never confronted that before so that's
actually my biggest fear and that you
know my shift in policy started with
misinformation as my biggest concern and
it remains my biggest concern but there
are others like there was a line that I
said in my Senate testimony which is
people will use these tools to
manipulate our um elections and our
markets and I didn't have a good example
this was only a few weeks ago in May I
didn't have a good example of the
manipulation of markets and then like a
week after I testified was this fake um
picture of the Pentagon on fire and that
did actually move the markets I don't
know if it was on purpose I don't know
why people did it but surely that sent a
sign to other people hey we could make
money shorting the market by putting out
misinformation so we're going to see
that that's another kind of risk we're
going to see lots of romance scams
basically automated where people use
these tools to you know do 100,000
romance or billion you know romance
scams at once so there you see a lot of
that kind of cyber crime um and that's
just short term longer term I think
there are other um concerns so I don't
worry so much about Extinction I didn't
sign the famous Extinction letter like
it's really hard to extinguish the human
species like liter get rid of absolutely
everybody um but there are a lot of
really serious things like you could
have accidental nuclear war either
caused by misinformation or by market
manipulation that leads to people to be
suspicious of other people that didn't
actually do things and they get mad and
there's
escalation there's a lot of very serious
risks yeah unwarranted military conflict
uh makes my risk list as well uh and
you've called for um some kind of
international body uh which I I agree
with when I was running for president I
pitched a world data organization that
uh was pitched to me by Ian
who just had a TED Talk that I know you
saw we actually met at Ted um I'll let
you finish your story but quick anecdote
about Ian is we met at lunch the day
before I gave my TED Talk and he said
what's your Ted talk about and I said
well imagine you're at a 60s protest and
you say what do you want or what do we
want International governance for AI
when do we want it now and he turns to
me and says six months ago his Ted Talk
was on a similar
uh topic as you know it's so fun to
imagine the two of you guys hanging out
in Vancouver together uh that that's
that makes me happy uh you know we had
fun there and then we met in New York a
few weeks ago so you know we've only met
a few times but all all recently we're
starting to um really click together I I
can see that uh you know I I like and
admire both of you um uh and uh humanity
is better for having the two of you
connected thank you so uh so an
international body um I I I've called
for uh something I'm not sure if you
included in your Senate testimony which
is uh an AI
dedicated regulatory body here in the US
what do you think about that idea yeah I
think absolutely I mean I think there
should both be a cabinet level agency or
office and then you know an agency
underneath that there's just too much
going on right now to expect that all
the existing agencies have it covered
they kind of wrote a memo kind of saying
that in in between the lines but the
reality is that the existing laws don't
anticipate certain things like we have
laws about protecting private individual
speech but what do you do if somebody
makes a billion pieces of harmful
misinformation a day we don't have laws
for that just to give you one example AI
makes things possible in a wholesale way
where they could only be possible retail
before it's sort of similar to like a
submachine gun versus a knife you have
to think about them differently um so
there a lot of new both opportunities we
want to take advantage of and a lot of
risks that that we need to look out for
I think we need somebody in the White
House whose job is full-time think about
this and nothing else um and they need a
staff to keep up with all of the
different parameters of it and this is
not to like cut out existing agencies
from the loop but we're going to need
some new things so for example I think
that we want to have something like FDA
approval if somebody's going to do
research that's one thing but if they're
going to roll out a system to 100,000
people or sorry 100 million people um
you know we really want to test it make
sure it's safe in the same way we do
with a drug we don't just say I did you
know trials on 10 people okay let's put
it out to every drugstore on the planet
we say let's show that you know this is
right and we need independent examiners
to say you've made this case but there
are weaknesses in your case we need to
understand this better you say that
there's this risk you don't have
anything about the risk we also need an
agency to push the companies to be
transparent you have Microsoft saying
transparency is important to us and then
they use gp4 and we don't know what's
inside of gp4 we don't know what it's
trained on which has a huge influence on
things like bias so we need someone to
really hold the company's feet to the
fire so I am 100% for um having an
agency like that and I've been talking
to people in Washington and trying to
talk up that idea as much as I can yeah
so after you went uh to the Senate your
testimony was very warmly received what
do you see as the prospect for some of
your recommendations being followed or
or uh a coherent regulatory approach hi
I like the word coherent that is that is
the the nub of it um on the one hand I'm
very inspired in certain ways so the
hearings that I was at hearing um was
one of the most bipartisan things I
think the Senate has done in a long time
and I think everyone I know who kind of
follows Washington more closely than I
do was amazed at how Cooperative it was
how much people recognize the urgency
genuinely seem to want to work together
seem to
um recognize that with social media they
didn't quite get things right and and
you know want to move quicker and better
so you have that on the positive side of
The Ledger on the negative side of
Ledger it sort of feels like everybody
in Washington has their own ideas about
what to do and they're not necessarily
all coordinated and talking to each
other and I wouldn't say there's any
one clear answer that has emerged yet
um and so like there's a lot
of motion but whether that motion turns
out to be coherent I think is the
question there's one moment I liked in
the Senate proceedings which was a kind
of recognition of their own limitations
I can't remember who who was that said
it but they said look we're not here to
legislate like the dayto day the way I
were to repeat it is the Senate
shouldn't be there to make rules for GPT
5 as opposed to GPT 4 the should be
there to create an enduring agency that
can move with the flow and follow all of
the details and I think you know some of
them realize that they don't want to be
micromanaging the details of AI
development if they get it right they
will build some agency that is Nimble
enough fast enough to be able to deal
with things as they move yeah that that
that the last thing you'd want is the
sen it have to check in anytime there's
a new
development they they don't want that we
don't want them to do that right I mean
with due respect I mean some of the
Senators are really following what's
going on like I saw Senator Blumenthal
on a call after the um proceedings and
he really understands all of the issues
he's following very closely but you
can't expect a 100 Senators to all you
know have their fingers on on the pulse
of AI they might like right now because
they're going to make a first important
decision but you certainly in the long
term they have so many other things to
focus on and so that they shouldn't be
micromanaging it
this podcast is sponsored by Helix sleep
it's a pretty short list of things you
can do that are going to make you
happier healthier more energetic more
productive every single day you know
what's on that list getting the right
freaking mattress and what's the right
mattress for you if you go to Helix
sleep you take their personalized sleep
quiz and they will send you one of 20
unique mattresses made for you and you
alone well not you and you alone like 5%
of people people do the math for 100
night free trial you can sleep on this
thing for 3 months it will keep you cool
don't just take my word for it my kids
seek out this mattress in the house it's
the number one rated mattress picked by
GQ and Wired Magazine this mattress will
actually make you happier healthier and
more productive Helix is offering 20%
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners go to
helixsleep.com yangang this is their
best offer yet and it won't last long
with Helix better sleep starts
[Music]
now it is my distinct pleasure to
Welcome to the podcast back in Ricky's
case the co-authors of the brand new
book The cancelling of the American mind
New York Post columnist and journalist
Ricky schlot and the president of fire
which which is the foundation or
individual rights and expression fire
Greg lukanov welcome Ricky and Greg
thanks so much a big fan of yours so
glad to be back thank you yes uh
congratulations on this book uh if if
someone looks closely they will see that
I have a blurb on this book so you know
I like
it the first one on the hard cover we
put it right at the top we were so proud
to have your endorsement because it's a
very very important work um but first
let's introduce or reintroduce people to
who the heck you guys are um so Ricky
you are a a whole 23 years old and yet
you're now the co-author of this major
book and I dare say that in some ways
you were set on this path by an
interaction with canel culture on your
college campus yeah actually I mean I it
goes back even to my high school campus
I was um 15 I guess in the 2016 election
and that was just it just disintegrated
my high school campus and then again in
college when I started to speak out
about my own political beliefs yet again
um definitely lost a lot of friends in
the process but also I would say I have
I have a glimmer of hope from that story
as well which I I can I can save for
later but um tell you a little bit about
how I think that cancel culture can be
kind of circumvented by by courage being
contagious but yes indeed cancel culture
I've I've known it since I was uh but a
shrimp in in high school
so yeah I mean that's one thing that
Ricky likes to point out that I think is
an excellent point is that we still have
to deal with people who are trying to
claim cancel culture isn't real or never
even happened which is just increasingly
I mean it's been a ridiculous statement
to make for a long time yeah but uh when
you PLL younger people about cancel
culture it's Generation Z that hates it
the most because they grew up in it they
they grew up not really trusting whether
or not you know that confidence they
they told to their friends is going to
make it onto Tik Tok and next thing you
know their their social lives are going
to be ruined so here's how I think the
average American might think about
cancel culture uh hey
uh occasionally people get cancelled but
it's mainly uh social media
related um it's not maybe that big a
deal I find it uh
unlikable uh but it's not something I
should be you know staying awake at
night thinking about now your book has a
number of um awesome contributions in it
uh it's a much more
rigorous uh cataloging shall we say uh
of cancel culture it breaks it down its
impacts and different institutions Ricky
you said that hey that a lot of this is
still on campuses which I think is where
most people think of it so let's start
at
campuses why why are college campuses
such a fertile ground for what we'd
consider cancel culture and for a moment
for people how would you define cancel
culture so I think that campuses are
really fertile ground for cancel culture
because you show up you're young you
want to fit in and often times there's a
very loud a liberal minority of students
who are tying people's viewpoints to
their their personal status or who they
are as human beings and and very
indulgent in these ad homenum attacks
and we attack people on social media and
when you're a kid that shows up and
you're afraid of putting yourself out
there and you think that like I did I
was hiding books under my bed like
Jordan Peterson and Thomas Soul you
really feel as though you can't put
yourself out there and I learned the the
kind of going off jumping off the cliff
and writing for the New York Post and
saying here are my viewpoints and I
think that free speech is a problem on
campus which was my first major oped all
the people around me felt the same way
or the vast majority I had people coming
out of every crevice of of Roommates of
um deans of of uh like whole departments
and professors that I had who would come
to me quietly and say oh I I completely
agree with you and good on you for
writing about free speech on campus but
just don't tell anyone that we had this
conversation and so I think there's
something about that highly ideological
bubble that really lets this go AR and
where those really aggressive loud
people who tear people down who use bias
response hotlines because the
Administration has just put this whole
bureaucracy around cancel culture and
basically indulging it it's it's the
tyranny of the minority just goes crazy
in real life in the same way that I
think it does in social media and then
in like the liveaction version on
college campuses essentially so Greg how
would you define cancel culture it you
it sounds like you have a a technical
definition yeah I I I do have I do and
this is the one of the few times I'll
sound like a lawyer but I want to be
precise about it and it's the uptick
beginning around 2014 and accelerating
in 2017 uh and after of campaigns to get
people fired disinvited deplatformed or
otherwise punished for speech that is or
would be protected by the First
Amendment and the climate of fear and
conformity that has resulted from this
uptick um because I'm trying to make
clear that we're not talking about
something that's strictly partisan
although the term cancel culture is
often times you know something that
people will accuse the left of being
guilty of and and certainly that's true
to a large degree uh but we also take on
cancel culture from the right because
what we saw after 2014 and it wasn't
subtle was just suddenly people were
rather than just being really
embarrassed on on Twitter or or Facebook
they were losing their jobs um for you
know jokes that that that went viral for
example um and on campus uh one of the
reasons why it is just so frustrating
that there are still people you know
trying to claim this doesn't this isn't
even happening the uptick in professors
getting cancelled is unlike anything
we've seen in the modern era of higher
education I mean the law protecting
academic freedom was and and free speech
on campus wasn't really clear until
about
1973 and there hasn't been a period like
this in that entire time when this many
professors are getting you know fired
tenured professors in many cases for
what they say what they print uh What uh
what they um and having their research
uh that that getting them in trouble and
some actually having withdrawn which is
which is usually considered an
extraordinary measure one of the goals
of of the piece was to of the book was
to put it all in one place and and try
to give some historical comparisons like
when you talk about uh sometimes people
have no it's very funny watching people
don't really know anything about the
history of freedom of speech claim oh
these are you know no these are tiny
numbers the it's not significant but
when you're talking about over a
thousand professors targeted you know um
just in the last nine and a half years
since canel culture began with about
two-thirds of those punished with uh
with about one of those about almost 200
fired you're talking about numbers that
blow away even things like the Red Scare
where where the normal estimates about
100 professors you know were fired and
and at the time every every knew the Red
Scare was happening like that that a lot
of that research actually comes it was
contemporaneous with it so it's been a I
try not to use this word too often but
it's been a a crisis on campus um and
and yeah we point out when about about a
third of those punishments um come from
usually the off-campus right and we call
those out uh as well but I do want it at
the same time I remember saying this to
somebody on on on social media I'm like
well but a third of them come from
conservatives like but you're implying
that the the rest come from the left and
it's like well yeah you you don't think
there's a free speech problem on on the
left on Camp like that that's that just
is willful blindness at this point yeah
and I might add that on the on the
right-wing cancel culture um kind of
side of things this is something that
like I know I'm going to take a lot of
flak for from some people that might
otherwise um like what I write about and
stuff but I have absolutely no problem
calling out what I see as ill fighting
illiberalism with il liberalism and
fighting might with might in a really
disturbing way because there's like a
wide opening for for people and leaders
to step in and say Free Speech has been
largely abdicated as a a major principle
of the left and here we are going to
actually step in and adopt that rather
than fight that hot mess that's
happening in the radical leftwing with
our own authoritarian hot mess on the
right which is just super disappointing
to me and I I think that there's such a
lack of a a positive restorative road
map to like how how can one one side or
no side or just a group of people in the
center or people who just are actually
classical liberals reclaim those values
and it feels as though that's not a
conversation that happens often enough
and it's like oh we're the champions of
free speech on the right but then here
are all our very authoritarian bills
that actually curb free expression at
the same time it's it gets my blood
boiling
this podcast is sponsored by
expressvpn going online without
expressvpn is like changing while
leaving your window wide open gross you
might not have anything to hide but why
give random creeps a chance to invade
your privacy that's why I use expressvpn
it's super easy you hit a button and
then you just beam in best of all you
know no one can see what you're doing no
big tech company
no ad companies no other companies why
use expressvpn when you go online it is
just you and your surfing no one can see
it you know it's the way to go because a
bunch of big companies say hey all of
you high-end consultants and spies use
expressvpn secure your online activity
by visiting expressvpn.com slang today
that's ex p svpn
n.com and you can get an extra 3 months
free expressvpn.com
yangang we have a special interview I
did with futurist and founder of the
xprize Peter diamandis for his podcast
moonshots Andrew let's flip to your
second moonshot which is the idea of
universal basic income um so uh the idea
just to lay it out as I understand it
and I welcome your your modification
here is as Ai and Robotics and other
exponentials 3D printing arvr blockchain
start to disrupt the job markets and
people uh lose their jobs to technology
um that we need to do a few things one
of them is going to be to help uh level
up those individuals up skill them to
better skills but potentially at least
in the interim is give them reliable
income uh a universal basic income that
allows them to you know put food on the
table get insurance um not feel panicked
uh perhaps get a better education
perhaps invest in whatever Tech they
need to start a small business uh and
it's about human dignity to a large
degree um and getting rid of fear
because there going to be a lot of fear
as AI steps in in a bigger way in the
next uh few years um I'll say one more
thing and then this is your platform and
you did a huge amount to I want say
necessarily popularize but educate
people about Universal basic income
which I'm I'm grateful for um the other
thing I wanted to mention is uh it is
something that's not a theoretical uh
concept cep it's been implemented and
tested and uh and studied uh over dozens
if not hundreds of experiments both in
the United States and around the world
so that's my setup for it and I want
people to understand it's uh this is
coming because we need a counterveiling
force to the fear that people have about
potentially losing their jobs well I I
love the way you frame that Peter the
the way I describe it is that you have a
mindset of abundance and possibility and
optimism and Entrepreneurship and then
you have a mindset of scarcity fear Us
Versus Them
xenophobia uh uh and negativity towards
technology honestly and so which of
these things is winning which of these
is going to win um I think you'd be
hardpressed to say that Nationwide the
mindset of optimism and possibility is
winning it's definitely winning at
abundance 360 which was a blast like go
there it's like I was uplifted because
here are people who are literally
building the the future but then you
know you drive a few hours in any
direction and you wind up at like a
let's say a different mindset um and so
the the question is how do we help
people transition there are a lot of
very smart folks who are deep in AI
who've also been um studying the effects
of Ubi or cash relief programs and one
of the things I think is going to appeal
to folks uh like you is that right now
we have the worst of all worlds where
we're spending so much money and energy
on dysfunctional administration of
programs that are really punitive and
dehumanizing I spoke to thousands of
Americans who are on various Aid
programs and the single biggest thing
that motivates them is fear they are
scared stiff of losing their benefits
there was a woman in Iowa who said to me
uh I would like to volunteer for my
local nonprofit but I'm scared to
because I'm on disability and I'm afraid
that if someone saw that I could
volunteer they'd take my money away yeah
and so you listen to that story and you
think my gosh like what have we done
where This Woman's getting the money but
instead of using the money to live a
better life she's staying in because
she's afraid of being seen as
able-bodied I mean like that that's
what's happening right now for millions
and millions of Americans where we've
set up this unfeeling machine above them
that they do not trust at all by the way
and said hey your uh subsistence is
going to be relying upon your staying on
the good side of this bureaucracy and if
you fill out the form wrong we're going
to pull a rug out from under you I mean
like I I i' I've spoken to military vets
who are in this boat I've spoken to so
many Americans and it it's uh we can do
better let's say yeah jelle sent me an
article uh which framed it as insecurity
versus uh inequality as the issue people
are facing they don't feel secure they
do not feel secure in the in the least
and if we can change that then we have a
much better chance of building uh
Society where if someone else makes some
rapid Advance you look at it and say oh
good like may maybe that's good for me
in some way right now unfortunately it's
more like like look at that jerk over
there who's doing well like you know um
uh like I'm not seeing any of that
you've studied this um if you had to uh
you know most people say listen if
you're sending people 500 bucks a month
it's going to be used for beer and
Netflix and it's a waste of money for
God's sakes why are you going to spend
my tax money to do that uh how do you
respond to that what's the data show oh
the the the data shows that people tend
to spend the money
on uh food fuel shelter books for their
kids uh activities for their kids uh and
the biggest example of that data set was
the enhanced child tax credit that was
implemented in 2020 and
2021 yeah in the US where it lifted
millions of American kids out of poverty
and 130 economists who looked at it said
we should keep doing this because the
money is getting used very very
effectively uh and uh American politics
being what it is we then pulled the plug
on that even though there were so many
uh literally there were Nobel lat saying
this is the best thing we've done in a
generation to alleviate poverty U but
the data is there for anyone to find um
you also saw saw saw decreases in things
like domestic violence child abuse uh I
mean if you put a little bit of money
into people's hands you talked about the
data Peter there was one study I found
very very compelling out of an Indian
tribe in North Carolina where One Tribe
started uh giving people a certain
amount of money because they had a
casino honestly and there was another
Tri I've got I've got it here it's the
Eastern uh band of Cherokee Indians
Casino dividend in North
Carolina uh and giving them no strings
attached between 4,000 and 6,000 per
year is that particular one and what and
you probably have it there that um you
had the kids uh learn better and their
even their personalities became U more
conscientious more trusting they were
education mental health decrease in
addiction and crime yeah yeah and by the
way if you wound up with people who do
turn to crime and drugs we end up paying
for that too in ways big and small I
mean like that we're spending $30 to
$50,000 per individual per year who is
homeless or incarcerated uh in our
country so if it hits our institutions
it's a lot more expensive than that $4
and $6,000 that those uh kids got yeah
un lest you think that this is a a new
idea I'm just going to Rattle off here
the research that my producer Nick did
you know um we've seen this in Alaska
since 1982 uh Alaska's had uh their
their fund funded by by oil I mentioned
North Carolina we've had experiments in
New Jersey uh Pennsylvania Iowa North
Carolina Seattle Denver Gary Indiana a
number is a big study done in Stockton
uh California uh Canada uh England
Brazil Germany Spain the Netherlands has
done a number
Finland uh Iran Kenya uh Namibia India
China um so I mean this has been done
hundreds of times and as I read through
the details here it's
consistent that this investment has
super positive outcomes I haven't read
any place where it's been had negative
outcomes or a waste of money yeah it
it's much more effective than frankly um
starting up a new bureaucracy and then
saying hey guys uh improve the lives of
people that are not you um one of the
organizations in the space that some
people might have heard of is give
directly which is it transfers money
directly to people in developing
countries
uh now there's probably some skepticism
among your audience uh rightly so of
kind of a nonprofit industrial complex
or an NGO industrial complex um there's
probably that mistrust when it comes to
certain government bureaucracies that
are terrible at uh administering
benefits in a like a frankly a sane way
this skips the middleman uh and gets the
resources to where it'll actually do
good yeah and I I I've been a donor to
give directly I think it's a uh it's a
brilliant uh you know super low overhead
minimized overhead U process on a
personal level Peter the way that you
and I do this probably is we just tip
really well uh you know because you're
around someone it's like hey this is
going to be dollar for
dollar and it's such a beautiful thing
when when someone unexpectedly gets a a
large tip and you know for that evening
that moment you've changed their life
yeah it's a great great feeling I highly
recommend it yeah yeah uh so the
question becomes where does this money
come from uh you know can we afford it
and I'd like to play a few a few
conversational games here you know I
remember Jeff Bezos and a few other
folks said well if we're going to start
to see technological displacement of
jobs and a robot takes you know a house
cleaning job or a robot takes a factory
working job or an AI takes a physician's
job why don't we just tax that robot and
that AI uh for for that work it's being
done and then use that tax base to fund
a Ubi program does that make sense I
think taxing AI makes a lot of sense uh
I think um the practice of it might be a
little bit
trickier uh the where the money comes
from for starters I I don't know how
people are going to receive this so our
data right now is worth hundreds of
billions of dollars a year um to various
companies your data is going to be worth
more than others
Peter
thanks um but we're not seeing a dime of
that so uh one of the proposals I had
was look there should be a data dividend
where I'm not one to hold back uh
certain forms of development but if
you're going to be buying and selling my
data uh maybe I should see what's going
on and get a cut and you know and and um
that could be the start of multi
hundreds of billions of dollars uh type
measure
uh AI itself um could also and one of
the examples I use is that there are 2
million Americans who work at call
centers still and let's say that AI is
going to be able to do that job pretty
soon how much do those 2 million
Americans pay in taxes right now I'm
going to guess that they do pay taxes
and then the question is will the tech
company that used the AI pay anywhere
near that level in taxes history
suggests it will not um and so you'll
wind up replacing tax paying humans with
AI that um we might not see that kind of
revenue from unless we change the
system it is my pleasure to Welcome to
the podcast former Navy fighter pilot
engineer by training and now founder of
Americans for safer Aerospace Ryan
Graves welcome Ryan hey Andrew thanks
for having me here thank you for being
here so we're we're going to talk about
your work around uh unidentified aerial
phenomena and you flew how many missions
in the Middle East I I didn't count them
to be honest but I did fly uh more than
I have counted right now between op
operation inherent resolve and operation
during Freedom uh those are the
operations we've had in Afghanistan as
well as in the Iraq Syria area uh when
all the Isis work was kicking off well
thank you for your service to the
country thank you for risking your life
uh and thank you now for the case that
you're making which again um I was
joking with you before we started the
interview that when I was running for
president I told the American people I
would come clean about Area 51 and
whatever the government knew about
extraterrestrials um so you encountered
unidentified aerial phenomena at various
points during your military career
certainly so after our my first combat
deployment when we came back we upgraded
our Radars uh from the AP g73 to the 79
radar uh just a much better radar can
see more things and we started noticing
things that we weren't seeing just
earlier in the day with the other radar
and what we were seeing were just radar
contacts that we weren't expecting uh
they were typically
stationary uh 0.0 Mack uh and that's
stationary uh in the Stream if you will
of the air and so we're not expecting
anything to be stationary up there
unless it's Tethered to the ground and
even then it would be bouncing around uh
but these would typically be stationary
and when they were not stationary they
travel about 6 to8 Mach uh which is
upwards of about 350 knots uh in either
circular patterns or RAC trck patterns
or just heading out east over the ocean
eventually we got close enough where all
our sensors inside of our jet they
essentially slew to whatever our radar
is looking at at this time we just
thought they were radar malfunctions not
physical objects that could uh hurt our
aircraft yet sure but eventually we got
close enough with our sensor systems to
actually make out the IR energy the
infrared energy that was coming off of
the the objects and so at this point we
had to respect that you know there was
physically something at that piece of
the sky uh and to you know avoid it the
best we could um of course you know
there was a investigatory period where
people said hey let's go take a look
with our eyeballs and and see what we
can find here and you know I was one of
those people and it was um it was
interesting we would have it on the
radar we'd have it on then the Fleer
system that IR system and all that's
getting pumped into our visor uh and
track to our eyeballs and telling us
exactly where to look and we do this
type of merging exercise quite often
where we fly up to something and we
assess its characteristics its weapons
loaded out um and we begin a dog fight
with it um in this case we would come up
to that merge and all our sensors would
show us where to look but then we
couldn't see the objects um we turned
back around and they would still be
there on the radar and on the Fleer uh
and that was kind of a status quo for a
while until we almost hit one of the
objects at the entrance to our work
working areas two aircraft from my
Squadron were entering the working areas
um side by side and at a very particular
altitude and GPS location is where we
enter those working areas and one of
these objects went right between the two
aircraft uh and the lead aircraft was
able to actually gain tally of it and he
described it as a black Cube inside of a
clear sphere about 5 to 15 fet in
diameter when you say gain tally of it
he actually saw it with his own eyes
correct with his own eyeballs to my
knowledge that was the first time we had
seen uh one of these objects with their
own eyes there's a black Cube within a
clear sphere MH and the tips of the cube
best we could assess to that point were
touching inside that clear sphere so
you're probably friends with the other
Pilots when when you got back and you
were saying hey what did you see and he
he described this you guys must have
been eager to hear more or flipping out
or something along those
lines we were moving along a progression
right we went from rad R errors to
something physical but not knowing what
they were but when we saw it physically
like that our first thought you know we
were never all about UFOs or or uaps as
they're called now that really never
entered into our conscious other than
something to laugh at um so we always
thought there was a very pragmatic
explanation if we just had enough
information um and at this point when we
physically saw it like I said as that
Cube we assumed that some this must have
been some kind of strange classified
program or drone program that must have
gotten too big for its britches and
essentially has been operating in a
place that they shouldn't have been
perhaps by accident perhaps not but
either way something had to be done and
due to the nature of this near midair uh
I mean we were obligated to file a
Aviation safety report due to close
proximity and that's what we did uh we
started filing them within the aviation
safety hazard Reporting System um and
that was again status quo for the time
being we essentially just stiff armed
them we tried to avoid them if if they
were in our working areas which they're
out there pretty much every day in some
capacity um we would just you know Flex
to a different area and do our best to
avoid them what what years uh were were
this and um what part of the world yeah
so this is right off the coast of uh
Virginia Beach Virginia uh and this was
in the uh 2014 to 2015 time frame you so
you follow the report but it sounds like
it's pretty much common knowledge among
Pilots that hey are these things out
there they're going to hit your radar in
a particular way um they seem like
actual objects like if you get close
your instruments all start saying hey
that the thing's there and you want to
try and avoid them because if you hit
one no one knows what happens we would
assume it would be I mean catastrophic
to the aircraft I mean based off of what
we were seeing uh there's no question in
our mind that you know this would result
in loss of aircraft like if we hit
anything of that size out there so it
seems like if you retrace the mythology
around these beliefs uh there was a
point uh earlier when I think it was um
a really suspicious International
environment there's like a cold war and
E Espionage um uh and so there is like
this sense that there were a lot of
Secrets out there and and uh and you
also had a sense at that time that um if
someone were to evince something like uh
beliefs and and UFOs
then it truly would be politically
self-destructive or professionally
self-destructive and and I feel like
times might have shifted since then
because uh like that there's almost like
a greater openness to the fact that we
might not know something or that
institutions might not be playing it
straight like what what do you think
about the direction of American um
culture and the fact that now I think
that we'd be open to things that uh in
the day we wouldn't have been yeah I
think you're absolutely right I mean
during the Cold War was a very much uh
fearful Society both uh internally where
I think there was distrust between the
branches and fear of Soviet you know
internal spies in the government as well
as you know obviously a lot of
international distrust uh and fighting
um so there there was you know my
understanding is that even more not even
more so but in addition to that there
was also a fear that due to the high
amount of UAP reporting or UFO Reporting
that it was actually going to be
something that the Soviets could take
advantage of by buding air assets into
our airspace under the cover of uh UFO
clutter uh and get caught up in in too
much reporting and so one of the
methodologies that was undertaken was to
diminish and push down the reporting um
so that the systems weren't overwhelmed
with anomalous objects and that you know
airplanes and air threats could be
identified but you know that's a little
historical context but you know what we
see today as Society has adapted with
our new tools and our technology and our
ways of communicating I feel like we're
much more adaptable and flexible to
changes in our society uh we're also
much more open to new ideas uh and
pushing past those kind of historical
boundaries and that's really I think
what makes us exceptional and that's
what's going to move the conversation
forward and why I think it hasn't just
gone away because once we we're at a
point in our society where we can latch
on to an idea like this and it's it's a
powerful motivator and people are really
passionate about these ideas and with
the tool to communicate you can't just
shut that conversation down anymore um
and so I I I see this as a conversation
that's going to continue to grow for
that reason uh because people can find
people with similar interest and that's
that's what's happening so you obviously
have the most direct experience with uh
the Eastern Seaboard here in America uh
the Navy the dod is this something
that's happening worldwide uh to the
extent that you have exposure to pilots
in uh other parts the world certainly
from from my understanding historically
this conversation goes back you know
let's just say since uh the 50s or 60s
there's been reports uh internationally
of events occurring not just from
civilians but from military and
commercial pilots as well uh I don't
think that there's a complete enough
picture on that and there's some natural
boundaries about what we want to share
with our International partners and how
we do that you know especially in the
Modern Age here but I think going
forward the way
really bring this conversation to
something of conclusion if that even can
be done uh is to really engage with the
International Community on this topic
and say hey we invite you all to you
know help us figure this out because I
don't think uh America or one group
within the United States uh really has
the authority to speak for the entire
world to say it's none of you and it
must be this so I think we really need
to bring in the International Community
and look at this um as a globe and see
where we can draw our conclusions then
yeah it could be a real opportunity for
some kind of global I don't hesitate to
say Unity but at least uh cooperation
mhm so when it comes to explaining these
phenomena um the most common
explanations are equipment malfunction
which at this point I think you can rule
out given the ubiquity because you know
it's like happened over and over again
uh foreign military domestic military
something civilian or extraterrestrial
are those like the
the four major categories mostly I would
say instead of extra trust I would just
throw it in the other bucket uh because
it starts we start to you know bacon
some assumptions if we look at things
extraterrestrial and the fact is we have
something anomalous but we don't know
what it is people ask me all the time
you know what what do you think it is
you know what is it really and we're
just not there we're not at a point
where we can necessarily draw
conclusions on it now you you've you've
said it could be ours it could be
someone else's on this planet or or it
could be something else that we haven't
identified that is either from here or
from somewhere else but we have to
continue to gather data about that
before we can draw those conclusions um
we've had baked in assumptions in this
conversation for so long even with the
name UFO flying objects um we've
identifi or we've updated the terms in
the last uh National Defense
authorization Act of
2023 uh to have unidentified anomalous
phenomenon because we have identified
there there is an anomaly there we don't
know if they're flying or if they're you
know in space or what domain but we
truly do have that mystery and we need
to get to the bottom of it yeah some of
the descriptions you have about uh them
just being still even though there are
gale force winds around them in a way
that would be very very difficult I mean
it it does seem truly anomalous and
doesn't like doesn't seem like they're
yeah they're like obeying the laws of
physics sometimes at least at least at
least that's the sense I get it's
confusing you know you're they operate
in a way that we're not expecting to see
so at first it's almost like well this
is must be some kind of software or
something of that nature but when you
realize it corresponds to reality um it
it it breaks your brain a little
bit